The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
B support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
VICTOR COSTAN: Any questions
about the sorting methods
that you want me to go over
in that while I revise?
OK.
All right, sorting.
What sorting methods
have we learned?
Let's start from
dumbest to smartest.
AUDIENCE: Merge sorting.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK,
somewhere in the middle.
Merge sort isn't very bad.
What's the easiest
method to sort?
AUDIENCE: Insertion.
VICTOR COSTAN: Insertion sort.
Excellent.
All right.
What else?
Heapsort.
And?
I gave two away now.
AUDIENCE: Counting.
VICTOR COSTAN: Counting sort.
Very good.
And?
Oh, wow.
If you don't even
have the name of it.
So the last one is radix sort.
What are the running
times for these three
that you guys remember?
AUDIENCE: Insertion sort
is linearly one more.
It's bad.
VICTOR COSTAN: I want to see our
pseudocode for insertion sorts.
AUDIENCE: n squared.
AUDIENCE: Now that's really bad.
VICTOR COSTAN: So linear is as
good as you could possibly get.
So sorting takes an
array of random stuff
and outputs an array of
things in a sorted order.
The array is size n, so it has
to output an array of size n.
If you can do an algorithm
that runs in order n time,
then that's the best you
could possibly accomplish,
because you have
output n elements.
So the best possible time
you could get for sorting
is theta of n.
All right.
How about merge sort?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Thank you.
Heapsort.
AUDIENCE: Order h.
Order h is log n.
VICTOR COSTAN: Order
h where h is log n.
OK.
And you're missing a factor.
So a heap operation takes
order h, which is log n.
So if I have to insert
a numbering in a heap
or extract a number from
a heap, that's log n.
In order to start an array,
how many insertions do I do?
AUDIENCE: I think--
now I don't know.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Wild guess.
AUDIENCE: n.
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
See, there you go.
So you need to insert all
your numbers in a heap
and then extract
them one by one.
And you will get them
in the correct order
that gives you the
sorted results.
So n log n.
Does anyone remember what's
special about these three
sorting methods that does
not apply to the other two?
AUDIENCE: They're in place.
VICTOR COSTAN: Merge sort
isn't quite in place.
If it would be in place,
it would be perfect.
There is actually a way of
making in place merge sort,
but it requires a PhD
degree to understand that.
So we will not cover it in 6006,
because I do not understand it.
So I couldn't explain it.
So merge sort is
not quite in place.
Which one is in place?
AUDIENCE: Heapsort.
VICTOR COSTAN: Good.
So heapsort is in place.
Merge sort is not in place.
And insertion sort
is really slow,
so we don't care
that much about it.
So what's special
about these three
that does not
apply to these two?
AUDIENCE: You don't
have to use integers.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
You don't have to use integers.
What do they want
to know instead
about the things you use?
So we'll call them keys.
AUDIENCE: You need to
be able to compare them.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
AUDIENCE: You don't
need to have a minimum
and a maximum integer.
VICTOR COSTAN: So turns out, if
you have a comparison operator,
you will have a
minimum and a maximum.
But that's complex
abstract algebra
that we don't need
to worry about.
So you gave me the
good answer, which
is we use something
called a comparison model.
And in that model,
you do not need
to know too much
about your keys.
So the elements in the
area that you're sorting.
Your keys are blobs.
And all they have
to be able to do
is know-- if you
have two of them--
you have to know
which one's greater.
That's it.
Nothing else.
What's the problem with
the comparison model?
AUDIENCE: It takes
time to compare things.
It's like with everything.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah.
So we learned in
lecture that there
is a lower bound for
the comparison model.
And if you want to sort using
nothing but this information,
that will take you at
least n log n time.
You cannot do better than n
log n if all you're using is
comparisons.
So in that respect, merge sort
and heap sort are optimal.
If you want to stay
within this model,
this is the best time
you're going to get.
Does anyone know how you can
implement this comparison model
in Python?
So numbers respond to
these operators, right?
Actually, in Python
this is equals equals.
What if I have a
random object and I
want to make it respond
to these operators?
So for example, I
write merge sort.
We wrote merge sort.
And now I have my own
objects, my own keys
which are not
necessarily integers,
because that's why we like this.
And we want to make them
respond to these operators.
So I can call merge
sort on an array of them
and it will crash.
What do I have to do?
AUDIENCE: I mean, you
have to give the keys
values that can be compared.
VICTOR COSTAN: So suppose
this is my key class.
AUDIENCE: This is
lad, the lt, and gt.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
There's a magical
method in Python.
So there is the
old school model,
which you might see in
legacy code, which only works
in Python 2.x, which is you
define the method called
cmp that takes self and other.
And it has to return
a number that's
either smaller than zero, equal
to zero, or greater than zero.
And this maps to this.
So you'll see this in old code.
But you shouldn't
use it in new code.
On this, you have a
very good reason to.
Instead, the new
model says that you
define special methods called
lt, which stands for less than.
So it's this guy.
le, which is less or equal.
gt, which is greater than.
And ge, which is
greater or equal.
And if you look at our code
for pieces two and three,
we have some objects that
pretend they're keys.
And we have to
define these methods.
Also, when you
define these, it's
a good idea to define eq
for equality comparison.
And ne, which is this guy.
So these also take
self and other key
that you're comparing with.
And they return true or false.
So this will help you
understand the code better.
All right, so with
relatively little work,
you can have any wild object
you want act as a key.
And then you have
insertion sort,
merge sort, heapsort,
heaps, binary trees, AVLs.
Everything works, because
everything uses the comparison
model.
The problem is
this n log n bound.
It's not as fast as the best
possible sorting algorithm
you could come up with.
This is slower than this.
So that's why we have to break
out of the comparison model.
And we have to look into these
boxes and get more information,
so that we can write
faster sorting algorithms.
Does anyone remember the
running time for counting sort?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] again?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: n plus e.
Let's remember how
counting sort looks like.
Let's get this array that-- that
should be enough-- four, one,
three, two, three.
How do we sort it
using counting sort?
AUDIENCE: We initialize an array
of all the possible values.
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
Very good.
So counting sort needs to know
something about your values,
right?
It makes an assumption.
And the assumption
is that these values
are integers from 0
to, say, k minus 1.
So you have k possible values.
And they don't really
have to be these as long
as you can map them
to these numbers.
So we are going to
initialize an array.
Let's say this is an array.
And zero, one.
So zero, one, two,
three, four, five.
So we're going to
initialize it with--
AUDIENCE: Oh, zeroes.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
And then?
AUDIENCE: Iterative
over our list sort
incrementing the corresponding
value to each key in your--
VICTOR COSTAN: So which
one am I incrementing here?
AUDIENCE: Pardon?
VICTOR COSTAN: Which one
am I incrementing here?
AUDIENCE: Zero ne through four.
One.
VICTOR COSTAN: Three, two.
And then?
AUDIENCE: Three n.
So this becomes a two.
And what do I do now?
AUDIENCE: Reiterate over
that-- I don't know.
I don't know what to call that
identity [INAUDIBLE] almost?
OK, an array.
Printing into your output array
one one, one two, two threes,
one four.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
So there's no zeroes
and now fives.
So one one, one two,
one three, and one four.
OK, so far so good.
This is great.
There's one thing
that's missing.
For counting sort and for
other sorting algorithms,
we care about the
property called stability.
And stability means
that if you have
two equal keys, or
at least two keys
that look equal to
the sorting algorithm,
they might be different
objects, because they
might be implementing that.
The one that shows
up first in the input
should also show up
first in the output.
And that requires
particular care,
because you can't
just look at the keys
from your sorting
perspective and know
which one's supposed
to go where.
You have to remember where
they were in the input.
So if this guy is 3a,
and this guy is 3b,
I can't use this
approach anymore, right?
Because when I'm
outputting here, all I know
is I have to output a three.
I don't have any
other information
associated with the key.
So instead, I have to
do something smarter.
AUDIENCE: Either replace
your array with a 2-D array.
Or I think better
would be to replace
each value with a length list.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So we can replace each value
with a length list, which
would have the keys
that map to it, right.
So here I would have a one.
Here I would have a two.
Here I would have
3a, and then 3b.
and here I would have a four.
So then I can go through these
and output them the right way.
OK, now suppose I'm
writing this in C.
Suppose I'm in a
low level language.
And I'm in a low level
language because I'm
hired by one of these startups
that are doing NoSQL databases.
And they're writing
everything in C
to make their
things really fast.
So I'm writing an index
that uses counting sort.
I don't have length lists,
because if I'm writing in C,
I have to write my own.
And that's hard.
So I want to implement
this in another way.
Length lists are hard.
What would I do instead?
Can anyone think of another way?
AUDIENCE: I think you
can decrement the values
for the C in the
array that you have,
where you have to type the
culture of each anyway.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, so
you have the right idea.
You're missing one step.
So I'll give
everyone else a hint
so that everyone can catch up.
So what I want to do is I want
to take this and transform it
into something that allows
me to go through the keys.
So I know I have five keys here.
I'm going to make an output
array of five elements.
And I want to be able
to see four and know
that it belongs here.
See one, know that
it belongs here.
See 3a, know that
Then probably update the
value associated with three.
See two, know that
it belongs here.
And then when I see 3b,
know that it belongs here.
So I want to look, when I get to
3a, I want to look inside here.
And I want this to tell
me that 3 belongs here,
3a belongs here.
So what would the
position of 3a be?
That's not good, right?
Let's call this c instead
so that I can say 3a be.
So how would I
define the position
using the sorted property?
3a should go in the index that
is how many keys smaller than 3
there are.
So if I can look
through here and see
how many keys do I have
that are smaller than 3,
this is where 3a needs to go.
If I look at four,
there are four keys
that are smaller than four.
So it needs to go
in position four.
AUDIENCE: Well, that almost
seems more like a compare.
I'm guessing that
makes it-- I think
it's kind of a comparison model.
But you're saying
is it greater than.
So it's not really counting
sort anymore as much.
VICTOR COSTAN: Well,
I'm telling you
I can compute that using this.
So I can use the
counting sort algorithm
and change this array a little
bit so that I can do this trick
and know what goes where.
AUDIENCE: You already
mentioned using a 2-D array.
VICTOR COSTAN: But a 2-D
array would be too much.
In the end, I will be
changing this in place.
So no extra space except
for this array of size k.
But let's not worry about
changing it in place right now.
Let's say we're going to
make another array of size k.
So I want it to tell me that-- I
guess I don't care about this--
but I want it to tell me
that one, the first one
should go here, the
first two should go here,
the first three should go here,
the first four should go here.
How do I do that?
AUDIENCE: Well, you could
make that array, right.
VICTOR COSTAN: But
how do I compute it?
AUDIENCE: While you're
making this one,
you can start
filling that one in.
But while you're
making the top one.
VICTOR COSTAN: Can I?
AUDIENCE: It would be like
insertion sort though, kind of.
So you come across the four.
You put it in there, because
you know how many there are.
But that doesn't
make a lot of sense.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah, OK.
So let's abandon that route.
Let's think of something else.
AUDIENCE: Could you
populate the array
with the number of elements that
are less than that [INAUDIBLE]?
VICTOR COSTAN: So
intuitively, I want
this to tell me how
many elements there
are that are smaller than two.
This should tell me
the number of elements
there are that are smaller
than three, so on and so forth.
OK, how would I compute that?
Let's see what it's
supposed to be.
Let's fill it out
with real values.
AUDIENCE: Zero.
VICTOR COSTAN: Zero.
How many elements
smaller than one?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
VICTOR COSTAN: How many
elements smaller than two?
AUDIENCE: One.
VICTOR COSTAN: How many
elements smaller than three?
AUDIENCE: Two.
It's a cumulative sum.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: On the array above.
VICTOR COSTAN: So this is
how many elements smaller
than four?
Or how many elements
smaller than 5 4?
OK.
what's the difference
between these two guys?
AUDIENCE: One.
VICTOR COSTAN: What's the
difference between these two
guys?
AUDIENCE: One.
VICTOR COSTAN:
Yeah, you're right.
Sorry.
Thank you.
What's the difference
between these two guys?
AUDIENCE: Two.
One.
VICTOR COSTAN: And what's the
difference between these two
guys?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, What
did I just write here?
AUDIENCE: Same series up there.
AUDIENCE: Array.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
So this guy is zero, right,
because there's no element
that-- there's nothing that's
smaller to the smallest key.
And then this guy is whatever
was here plus this almost.
So the difference between
this guy and this guy is this.
AUDIENCE: So why go
through an array?
I mean, why did you bother?
Why do we make a new array?
Because we could just
get that information.
VICTOR COSTAN:
Making a new array
so that we can see
how to compute it.
So now we're going to try
to right pseudocode that
does this in place.
So suppose this
array is a and this
array is pass for position.
And suppose-- sorry,
not this array.
This array is a.
This array is pass.
And I start with this.
And I want to end up with this.
So let's try to write the
pseudocode for counting sort.
Counting sort with an array a.
I'm not going to write the first
two lines that produce this.
Let's transform this to this.
How would I do that?
AUDIENCE: Initialize an
array of the same size.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Can we try to do it in place?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
VICTOR COSTAN: How
do we do it in place?
AUDIENCE: You could, well
for four, you get the four.
You're like, oh, I haven't
encountered anything below me.
So you put it in zero
initially for four.
And then you get a one.
And you're like, oh, I haven't
gotten anything below me.
But I forget to keep
track of the fact
that you have to iterate a
whole list ever single time
you get a new input.
VICTOR COSTAN: So I
don't want to do that,
because that's n squared.
AUDIENCE: What you need to
do is keep a running sum.
Is it a register?
Is that what you do call it?
VICTOR COSTAN: Running sum.
I like running sum.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Keep a running sum of--
VICTOR COSTAN: Sums always
start at zero, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
So you keep zero at--
you take the value
in each index of that
array and add it to sum.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So for i iterating
from zero to-- so you
want each value in
this array, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
VICTOR COSTAN: So it's going
to iterate from zero to what?
How many elements
do I have there?
AUDIENCE: Length k.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, almost.
So we're using Python numbering,
which is zero base indexing.
The indices look like this.
So it's zero to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
Thank you.
And you said I'm going to
add the elements to a sum.
So sum is sum plus
position of i.
OK.
And then?
AUDIENCE: The replace
is the [INAUDIBLE].
So zero should be zero still.
One should be the sum
after evaluating zero.
You'll need a temp variable.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: You'll need to
graph position i when in temp.
VICTOR COSTAN:
Temp is position i.
AUDIENCE: Then say position i
is sum before incremental sums.
No.
That's not it at all.
VICTOR COSTAN: Really?
AUDIENCE: We'll have to say
that sum is sum plus temp.
That is going to work.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
How does everyone
else feel about this?
Does it make sense?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
temporary blast [INAUDIBLE]
previous adjuration, because--
so when you first started,
it's the very initial
case that doesn't work.
So like, if you're in the first
column, everything's fine.
Then you go to column one.
You're looking at everything
to the left of it.
It's still going to be zero.
Then you go to
the second column,
but you already overwrote
the previous column.
So you need to store
somehow the-- I don't know.
It's just the initial
case from when it first
goes from zero to an
actual qualified number.
Because otherwise,
you're just going
to get like zero, zero, zero.
And you just overwrite.
AUDIENCE: Can you
start [INAUDIBLE]?
Was that before you changed?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Sorry, I'm getting confused.
This is getting hard.
I will show you a trick
to make life easier.
I'm going to put-- how many
elements do I have here?
Five, right?
So I'm going to put a
five here after the array.
And then I'm going to ask
you, what's this difference.
AUDIENCE: Zero.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So now we have this whole array.
Can people see what's
going on here.?
So instead of starting
at the beginning,
I'm going to start at the end.
And I'm going to know-- I know
for sure there are n elements.
Therefore, the index of
this guy is n minus--
so the index of the last key
is n minus how many keys I
have with this value.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: But you're iterating
over an order, right?
So we can't just
take the whole thing
and say we're going to
shift it over to the right.
VICTOR COSTAN: How about--
AUDIENCE: And you're going
through left to right.
You'll only know what
you see thus far.
VICTOR COSTAN: How about going
it for ai from n minus 1 to 0.
Will it work then?
So what would I write?
AUDIENCE: But isn't
that super inefficient?
Because then you're starting
looking at the whole list.
And then you're sort
of, rather than just
looking at the previous sum
that you just-- the cumulative.
So your first
adjuration, you have
to add up everything
that you see.
Like adjuration, you have
to add everything up.
VICTOR COSTAN: So if I
add everything up here,
what's the result going to be?
AUDIENCE: Five.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
What's five?
So this counts
how many zero keys
I've seen, how many
one keys I've seen,
how many two keys I've
seen, so on and so forth.
So in total--
AUDIENCE: So you're subtracting
VICTOR COSTAN: It's how
many keys I've seen.
All this, the sum of all these,
is how many keys I've sent.
How many keys do I have?
AUDIENCE: Five.
For each one you
see, you can just--
VICTOR COSTAN: So who's five?
It's the length of
this guy, right?
And we usually call that n.
So when we're doing
sorting, this is n.
So maybe it's less confusing.
Oh, I already used
n in two places.
So I guess that's it.
I could say the length
of a, but there you go.
So I could do the thing that
we're going through before.
I could figure out
my temp variables.
And I could make it work.
Or I could do this.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
the same though, isn't it?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yup.
It's the same thing, except I
think this is easier to write.
Does anyone want to
help me write this?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
doing once you're
starting with the top array,
and then finding the bottom one.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Well, you just-- you
start with the first one
and the one ahead of it.
And oh, I mean starting
with the top right.
Sorry.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK,
so I have this.
And then what do I do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
Oh, so you're starting
from the back.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Well, then you just
compare that to-- I mean,
you're going to start
with zero difference.
If you have-- well you don't
have any of those last keys,
so you'd be able to
start with a zero.
VICTOR COSTAN: So what's
the difference between five
here, which is n, and this guy?
What is this?
AUDIENCE: It's going to be zero.
VICTOR COSTAN: But what is it?
Why is it zero?
So this one's zero, this
one's one, this one's two.
What is this?
It's the last guy here, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
VICTOR COSTAN: So this
is pass of n minus 1.
And this is pass of n minus
2, so on and so forth.
So to get from n
to the value here,
I have to subtract this guy.
AUDIENCE: Pass of i.
VICTOR COSTAN: Pass of i.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Very good.
AUDIENCE: And then update sum.
Sum equals a pos value.
VICTOR COSTAN: Sweet.
No temp variables, aside
from this, I guess.
How does this look like?
Do people get it?
AUDIENCE: You're
subtracting positive i,
or you're subtracting a of i.
AUDIENCE: It's all one array.
AUDIENCE: It's the same thing.
That's right.
VICTOR COSTAN: So a is this
array. a is the input array.
And pass is this guy.
And this is pass
before the four loop.
after the four loop.
So I guess this is pass zero.
And this is pass one.
And here, we start
with pass zero.
This, we end up with pass one.
OK
So we're able to compute this.
There are many ways of
doing this, but in the end,
you want an array
that looks like that.
This is counting sort.
This is the hard part of
counting sort, coming up
with that array.
Once you come up with
that array, you're golden.
So let's see that we're golden
and produce an output array
with the keys in
the right order.
So say we have an
array called output.
And this is going to have
these keys in the right order.
What's the pseudocode for that?
First, I'm going to
create a new array.
And I'm going to initialize
it with n NIL values.
Then what do I do?
AUDIENCE: Iterate over a.
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
For-- nah, it's too low.
Let's do it here.
AUDIENCE: i of a.
From zero to n minus 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: Out of
[INAUDIBLE] has to be-- oh,
can we modify pass one as we go?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you could
say, out of pos one--
VICTOR COSTAN: So by
the way, this is pos.
The reason I label
them with zero and one,
so we're doing the
change in place.
AUDIENCE: Right.
VICTOR COSTAN: The
reason I labeled
them is to say that
this is what pos
is before we going
into the loop.
This is what pos is afterwards.
But it's a single array.
So let's call it pos.
So out of pos of--
AUDIENCE: Pos of i
equals a to the i.
Positive i plus pos squared.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yup.
And I'm going to use
the CLRS, the way
which makes me write more.
So how this work?
I have the survey here.
I start at four.
What's pos of four?
AUDIENCE: Four.
VICTOR COSTAN: All
right, so I'm going
to write this as position four.
I should probably make
this a proper array.
One two, three, four, five.
So at four, I write four.
And then I increment
this guy to become five.
Then I get to one.
So I look at pos of--
AUDIENCE: One.
VICTOR COSTAN: And that is zero.
So I'm going to write
one at position zero.
And I'm going to increment it.
Then I get to 3a.
I look at positive 3.
It says 2.
So I'm going to write 3a
here and increment this.
Then I get to two.
Pos of two is--
AUDIENCE: One.
VICTOR COSTAN: One.
So I write two here.
Pos of two becomes two.
Then I have 3c, which
is pos of 3 is now 3.
It's not two anymore.
So yay, I'm not overwriting 3a.
That's good.
And this becomes four.
Are people getting what
just happened here?
AUDIENCE: Wait, why didn't
[INAUDIBLE] to just basically
train the next array
into an index binder?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
So this guy tells
me if I have a key,
where do I write it in here?
So these start out with pointers
to the first element that
would store that key value.
And when I store a key, say when
I start 3a, when I get to 3c,
I don't want to store
it in the same place.
So I have to increment that.
I have to say, yo, I
wrote 3a at position two.
So next time, write
it-- next time you
see a three, right it at
the position following that.
And that's what this guy does.
So this is the
relatively easy part.
And this is the hard
magic in counting sort.
So how are people
feeling about it now?
Any nods, or is still
confusing as hell?
AUDIENCE: It's a lot.
I'm confused.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Well what should we do?
Do you guys want to
ask more questions?
Do you want to run
through another example?
Do you want to try to see how
this becomes useful in radix
sort, so that you're motivated
to figure it out on your own?
What would make more sense?
All right.
Who wants to do more count sort?
Who wants to do some radix sort.
All right.
Radix sort it is.
Next time you want to move
on, tell me understood
and I'll believe you.
And it'll look good on tape.
Two, three--
AUDIENCE: You're not
supposed to tell us
that there's a camera in here.
VICTOR COSTAN: One, four.
I think you're supposed to
know, because otherwise you
don't know that we're
violating your rights.
Two, four--
AUDIENCE: This is out the door.
VICTOR COSTAN: One, two, four,
three, two, one, four, three.
And one more.
One, two, three, four.
So this is to
refresh your memory.
What do keys look like
in merge and radix sort?
So in concert, the keys have to
be numbers from 0 to k minus 1.
How about merge sort?
What do keys look like?
So radix sort says that a
key is a sequence of digits.
Say you have d digits in a key.
But then each digit isn't
necessarily a base 10 digit
like we're used to.
Each digit is in base k.
So each digit can be
from 0 to k minus 1.
And we're using base k.
How many keys can I
represent this way?
So if you have numbers
of n digits in base k,
what's the biggest number
that we can represent,
or how many numbers can
we represent with that?
AUDIENCE: n to the k.
No, d to the k.
Right?
VICTOR COSTAN: Almost.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the d.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
So if our base is two,
like if we're using bits,
then our base is two.
And if I have eight bits,
then two to the eight.
Cool.
So if I add one
more digit, I get
to multiply the number
of keys I represent by k.
How do I radix sort?
Does anyone remember?
AUDIENCE: We checked the
log base k of everything.
I guess log base d.
Oh, k.
It's based in--
VICTOR COSTAN: No.
That would be hard math.
We don't do hard math.
In sorting, if you have
integers going into your sort,
you only do integer operations.
You don't do anything
math beyond them.
So what we do is we've
broken up the keys
into d digits for a reason.
We're going to have
d rounds in the sort.
And in each round, we're
going to take all the keys
that we have.
And we're going to sort them
according to one of the digits.
So in one round, we'll sort
them according to this digit.
In one round, we'll
sort them according
to this digit, this
digit, this digit.
Which digit do we start with?
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: To least
significant digit, right?
AUDIENCE: And most
significant on the left.
VICTOR COSTAN: So this or this?
AUDIENCE: The right side.
AUDIENCE: 100 is
bigger than 1, even
though the 1 is greater
than the 0 in 100.
VICTOR COSTAN: You're
helping me out.
So the point I'm
trying to make here
is radix sort is unintuitive.
If we ask you on a quiz
what do you start with,
your intuition will
tell you to start
with the most significant digit.
Go against it.
In radix sort, you start with
the least significant digit
and then move your way out.
So radix sort goes like this.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
it does make sense,
because you don't have very
much information unless you're
looking at bits.
You can get a bunch
of twos, but that
doesn't give you
much information.
The most information
is the smallest bit.
And then you move up from there.
VICTOR COSTAN: It
depends what information
you're trying to get.
But maybe you know the
algorithm, so you're thinking,
oh, by knowing the
algorithm, I know
that I'll have the
most information
by looking at it this way.
All right, so let's sort
these by the last digit.
Sweet.
Let's sort them by the
digit, by the digit
before the last digit.
What do I have to
do in my sorting?
pay attention to?
So the sorting method that I
use has to have a property.
It can't be any kind of sorting.
Stable.
So the reason we went through
all this pain in counting sort
is because we want to
have a stable sort here.
Now, let's try to sort
these in a stable manner.
This is the first one,
two, four, one, three.
Then I have two threes, so one,
four, three, two, one, two,
three, four.
And then I have three fours.
Two, three, four, one.
Two, four, one, three.
Two, one, four, three.
Way this isn't good.
Two, three, four, one.
One, two, four, three.
AUDIENCE: You should cross them
off if you write them down.
VICTOR COSTAN: I should.
I was hoping you guys
would help me if I mess up.
So now these are sorted stably.
Let's look at these last three
that have the same digit here.
So they have the same four.
If you look at the
last digit, because I
used a stable
sorting, they're also
sorted according
to this last digit.
So they're sorted according
to these last two digits,
because the sorting
that I used is stable.
So now if I sort
according to this digit,
then if my sorting
is stable, they're
going to be sorted according
to the last three digits.
So as I go from my last
digit to my first digit,
the keys are going to
be sorted according
to the last digit, the last
two digits, the last three
digits, and then all the
way up to everything.
This is why I need
a stable sort.
And also, this is why I
need to start from the end.
Does this make some sense?
What stable sort
did we just learn?
AUDIENCE: Counting.
VICTOR COSTAN: Counting sort.
All right.
So we're going to use
counting sort for this.
What's the running
time for one round?
So for one sorting.
One counting sort
takes how much time?
AUDIENCE: This is a radix sort.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes.
So radix sort is d
rounds of counting sort.
Count sort this,
count sort this,
count sort this.
So one round, one counting
sort, what's the running time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Thank you.
Now how about d of these
plus the running time?
AUDIENCE: dn plus b.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, but I
want to come back here.
And I want to be able to say
that radix sort is optimal.
I want to be able to
say that it is order n.
So what do I have to do in
order to be able to say that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
k equal to m.
VICTOR COSTAN: So you're going
from-- you know the answer.
You're going from the fact
that you know the answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: OK, very good.
What if we wouldn't
know the answer?
What do I need to do?
AUDIENCE: Well, we know
the first part is order n.
So--
VICTOR COSTAN: So d has to be--
AUDIENCE: We want dn to
be greater than dk, right?
VICTOR COSTAN: Well, so dn.
dn has to be, at
most, o of n, right.
Because otherwise, the
whole thing would go above.
So that wouldn't work.
So then what can I say about d?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
And how do you write
constants in math mode?
AUDIENCE: Order one.
VICTOR COSTAN: Very good.
So d has to be order one.
Otherwise, it's not going
to come out to that.
Now, what else do we know?
We have this that's
order n plus k.
If I said this to be
a lot smaller than k,
if I set it to be log n,
it's going to be order n.
If I set it k to be a
constant, if I use bits,
if I use base 2-- so I said
k equal 2-- this is still
going to be order n.
So if k goes way
below n, this step
is still going to be order n.
So I might as well set
k as high as possible.
So k is order n, because
that's the highest
thing I could set it to.
Now why do I want to do that?
Yes, you have a ques--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] represent
in counting sort again?
The length of what?
VICTOR COSTAN: So
in counting sort,
n is your input, how
many keys you have.
And k is the size of this array.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
VICTOR COSTAN: So you
have to be able to map
your keys from 0 to k minus 1.
AUDIENCE: It's set
by n, basically.
Or it's set by the elements.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah.
It's set by the
nature of the keys.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Got it.
VICTOR COSTAN: So
in real life, we're
thinking maybe we have some huge
numbers that we want to sort.
And we're going to chunk
them up into-- when we're
writing on the
board, we always have
to chunk them up
in base 10 digits,
because that's the only
way we know how to write.
But in a computer memory, we
can chunk them up into, say,
base 10,000 digits.
And the fewer digits
you have, the faster
this is going to run.
So we have to figure
out what's the base.
And it turns out
that if you want
to have radix sort run
in order and time, well,
the number of digits has
to be sort of constant.
I know that k should
be order n, because I
have no interest in
making it lower than that.
So these two bounds
together tell me
that the keys that I
can sort are from zero
up to order n of order one.
And this looks terrible,
but what it comes up to
is that you can
sort keys that look
like n to some constant
for any constant.
So you can sort huge keys,
as long as huge still
means finite.
And as long as you can figure
out how to map them to numbers.
Does this make some sense?
Would we ever want to use merge
sort instead of counting sort?
Suppose we had a
stable merge sort.
Would we want to use that
instead of counting sort here?
What would happen?
So suppose it's stable.
So it's correct.
The algorithm isn't
going to blow up.
What's the running
time for merge sort?
So if I use a merge sort.
So if I use the merge sort, it's
going to be d times n log n.
So no matter how
small d is, I'm still
not running in linear time.
So merge sort does not
go well with radix sort.
So from my end, we're
pretty much done.
We started with n log n.
And we got to a sorting
algorithm that's order n.
We started at the beginning
of [INAUDIBLE], saying
that the best thing
we can do is omega--
is that omega-- omega of n.
We got to that limit.
We're happy.
We're going to be
done with sorting.
Any questions from you guys?
That means everyone's
confused, right?
Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
what the stability criteria
is again?
VICTOR COSTAN: The--
AUDIENCE: Stability for
these sorting algorithms.
Which ones are stable and
what makes it unstable?
VICTOR COSTAN: All
right, very good.
Thank you.
So I like especially
the last part,
with which ones are stable.
I'd like to go through that.
So a stable sorting
algorithm means
that if you have two
keys that are equal,
the key that shows
up first in the input
is the key that is
produced to the output.
So in this model, your keys
are not necessarily integers.
Your keys might be
those weird classes
that implement some method
that maps them to integers.
So say there is a
method there, __int__,
that gives you the
integer for that.
So the sorting algorithm
would only see a three here.
But in fact, this
is a complex object.
And this is another
complex object,
but the sorting
only sees the three.
If this guy shows up before
this guy in the input,
they have to show up in the
same order in the output.
AUDIENCE: Why would that
be bad if they're switched?
VICTOR COSTAN: It's not stable.
If they're switched, then when
we're using a stable sorting
algorithm here.
So here, the key is
this complicated object.
But say we're in
the second round.
We're in this round,
which we played with.
Even though the key is this
whole complicated object,
the only thing that the counting
sort sees is this number.
So this guy looks like three.
This guy looks like three.
And these three guys,
although they're different,
they look like four.
If I don't output them
in the right order--
say I output this one all
the way at the end-- then
I'm going to get two, three,
four, one to be down here.
And now my numbers aren't sorted
by the last two digits anymore.
So it breaks any algorithm
that assumes stability.
So stability is something
that you get from a sort,
because it's
convenient to assume it
in some other algorithm
that builds up on that sort.
If you don't need it,
you don't care about it.
But in some cases, you need it.
And for the second part,
which algorithms are stable.
Is insertion sort stable?
AUDIENCE: I assume so.
I mean, stable is
being correct, right?
VICTOR COSTAN: No.
We mean that property there.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
You mean in order.
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Insertion sort goes in order.
But I guess it could push
other things out of order.
VICTOR COSTAN: So
insertion sort,
you're doing swapping to
move things to the left.
But if you find two
things that are equal,
you're never going to swap them.
So insertion sort is
in order, is stable.
Merge sort, the one we gave
you in that list is not stable.
But there is the one character
change that makes it stable.
And you should look at
today's lecture notes
to find out what that is.
So merge sort can be stable.
Heapsort, stable or unstable?
Unstable.
And there's a
really small example
that you should look at.
Counting sort,
stable or unstable?
AUDIENCE: Stable.
VICTOR COSTAN: Thank you.
It would have broken my heart if
this would have come out wrong.
And radix sort?
AUDIENCE: Probably.
Yes.
VICTOR COSTAN:
Probably stable, right?
All right.
Any more questions?
I like that question by the way,
because you made me do this.
I like that.
Any more questions?
All right, thank you guys.